welcome to this video playing our
penguin well that's a good customer and
nine and a half out of 11 that sounds
good so we get some kind of Slav trying
the exchange Slav didn't play that for a
while and let's have some solid after
some solid game after I've been crushed
by yeah I've been crushed by Yardbird in
the game before it came so this is
actually a pretty nice lined with white
having good central control
pretty good stone wall type of position
uh-huh okay that's not a bad bad
structural change
now i'm happy with this will be a good
Bishop were this bad pic bishop scenario
in many cases check check okay so a 3 B
4 B 5 maybe a three maybe start with a
three I could have now on camera 96 root
g eight is ok yes hmm ok so before here
on yeah ok I have to watch a little bit
with the king and the rupiah lined up
I'm not stumbling into some tactic yeah
here i was thinking night a five
don't want to retreat him 195 takes f
cheeks
difficult to enter so I'm going here
that the King as a possible entry route
c3 before
it's easier to enter now compared to the
other structure so do I have something
better now than trading maybe a four is
an idea yeah he cannot advance they
might be able to after capture up chicks
like rook before would be six it's
probably okay my king is near the action
this is very important in many end game
scenarios him his king is not really
playing
that's the point 86
and I want to be sure to really win this
and game I need the King there so I'm
going to bring the King up first and
only then take on a six yeah so I wants
to go look these six that's interesting
Bishop and games not going to be winning
i guess so i have to grab the poor now
now it looks very comfortable with also
e6 being a very severe weakness Jack
rook be sexy will take king d six kings
ii three kings is six King be six wait
look b6 do I have to calculate that in
the first place I can probably bring the
king of cable physics texts Enki me 16 c
three kings is six King see for King be
65 so I can play it
let's play okay seven or something like
that now going age six wow really check
what age three should win pretty easily
age three kings ii 4g for not on g4
immediately is that better take stings
king you for
eight three kings ii 4g for King b3 take
the five text ex-king at five King III
king g5 King f3 we both promote at the
same time I met kind of kind of unfair
and thanked 0 g 4 immediately he takes
it kingi for Kings III can you file and
I just pushed those right okay
King c4f five should do the trick
check
check let's just take it it's easiest
time warning black resign yeah he really
quickly went into somewhat yeah somewhat
doubtful end game where you really were
playing where Blake was playing relief
or two results and win is not one of
them Jaya this kind of end game is
really low not oops now he's going
forward at or no is going backward no
he's going forward okay okay am back now
had you said and to open up a new nail
as a sport that my opponent cannot check
move on yeah this ending as i said is
pretty awkward and computer is going
here maybe this is even better going for
a quick 95 my king is playing and
long-term have the better bishop and
it's not very very convenient b5 this is
a very interesting moment now I think I
don't know I like Knight a5 it gives me
this idea of entering with the King
instead of 90 to e5 after 95 takes takes
I don't see how I can enter with the
King Ed's at any point I mean why it is
also bit better here simply because of
the bad scope of this bishop but I like
this more
a 4 immediately also was strong okay
again a for ya what he could have done
is this he missed this move so that
after a four he has a better defensive
set up this kind of thing it's also
better for me but not as good as in the
game here it's basically losing yeah the
engine is all plus plus two already
because I get exactly where I got in the
game and check yeah so Wow the computer
is not giving a clear win here this is a
bit shocking King si tu ya kin the rook
endgame should win somehow but why isn't
this winning i will get at King d6 here
King c6 here King p65 check so the
engine says this is a drawn really wow
I'm losing with King c4 wow I completely
miscounted hear what yes Kings you form
oh my god
poo Wow I completely miscounted design
Kim I should go here in g6 and the
engine gives a draw and he's just in
time wow this is awful could have pic
would have one day I with King see form
ah yeah King c4 was a draw no I'm
winning as it was in the game whoa very
bad technical play pool okay i guess i
need to break thanks for watching